what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey from podcast
one
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone we just become best friends yep
yay hi everybody welcome back to another
episode of the unwaxed podcast
do your classmates do it okay with your
hosts sophia and sistine
oh with your favorite sisters i messed
up already i'm sorry that is your
tagline
i know i know i think my mind is a
little jumbled because of what's gonna
happen today
i'm actually a little nervous for you
let's get into it why will your mind be
jumbled
you guys from day one i know cysteine i
always say we've always been so excited
to have a certain guest on but
this was something that we've been
talking about since day one was having
a psychic come on and not just a psychic
he's a medium
he knows a ton about um astrology no is
it um
is it astrology yeah yeah astrology and
he does palm readings he does tarot
cards he does
all of it all of it oh my gosh and
we have him on today and he is going to
be reading
sistine i volunteered her because i
didn't feel like anything i volunteer as
tribute
here's what happened sophia on monday
did a zoom reading with this guy
it kind of rocked our world a little bit
we'll give you a quick synopsis
of yeah of what we're reading and then
he's going to come on and he's going to
read me live
yep go ahead i just want to just start
out by saying one he was
accurate as hell it was so intense and i
mean i'm a very intense person with a
lot of things
sometimes i'm goofy but this one like
really hits the core
but i told me i shouldn't probably
explain what like
astrology is like the sun moon and
rising but i think you guys will hear a
lot of it
later on so i'm just going to give a
quick brief overview if you don't know
what it is
the day you were born is your sun sign
so that's basically i'm a virgo
and cesine's a cancer and that's just
who you are on the outside it's your
identity
your moon sign this is all based on the
day you were born the time
and the place you were born your moon
sign is your soul behind your identity
it's your emotional side
so i'm an aquarius and sistine's a leo
and then your rising is your social
personality
and i'm a gemini and sistine's a libra
with my combination i'm basically a
psycho overthinker who can't shut up
i'd like to interject really quickly for
all of the listeners out there that are
like me that have no idea what sofia is
saying right now
i'm here with you and we'll stand
together so we're really excited because
he's here
i'm currently staring at him right now
oh my god i feel i feel my fingertips
are tingling
you guys no one can sometimes read
sistine so now we get to finally have
someone
expose her that's the best thing every
time i encounter
when i'm on a date a friend i they
always say
you are extremely unreadable yeah so
let's see
let's put this guy to the test right now
let's see what he's got we'll be right
back
he is unlike any psychic we've ever seen
his readings are
real raw and 100 no [ __ ] and i
got that on monday when he did my
reading so chris medina isn't afraid to
call out the spiritual and false healers
he specifically focuses on what is
holding you back
and what your soul needs to evolve which
is definitely what i needed
and guess what everybody i volunteered
my sister to be vulnerable and expose
herself as chris
racer today live so here he is i am so
happy to have you on
oh my gosh thank you guys so much thank
you for having me i really appreciate it
i have so many questions
for her i want to know when she's going
to fall in love i know
she needs it because she's had some
trouble in the past love
is the one thing i definitely wanna i
also wanna know about it
well yeah so i wanna hear also about how
you started really quick and like
what got you to this place of reading
because i i know it's probably
not just something that someone comes up
to like oh you can take a career in
reading people it's probably something
that was thrust upon you i actually was
born with this ability
i know a lot of people come into the
game and they say that they got into a
traumatic accident or somebody died and
they passed this on to them
i was born this way right my father's
native american he's apache indian
oh wow so i've had this again my entire
life dealing with it working with it um
i did not use it for the best ways all
the way up until
i was probably in my late 20s getting
ready to go into 30s
oh okay i was severely bullied in school
i had nothing
so i used it for the wrong stuff i used
it to manipulate and lie
so if you think about it now look at my
karma now i'm coming here and i'm
helping people
that are being lied to that are being
taken advantage of right by psychics by
mediums by astrologers
full circle here yeah for sure did you
see dead people
yes oh god it's like the sixth sense in
real life
the last two weeks have been horrible
especially
yeah the energy has been all over the
place i have not been you can ask jay i
have not been able to sleep i've had
uh armenian man or a persian man i don't
want to you know be racist but maybe
we'll say middle east yeah come to me
and was telling me this was about
last week can you please do something
about my wife and my daughter
they keep fighting over the stuff that i
left behind specifically a gold bracelet
and i know that sounds hokey but it's
true no wait
so do do that stuff have you ever like
like had been approached by a ghost and
you were like i need to fix the
situation or else they won't stop
bothering me
i turn them away there was one i'll give
you a good one here i was watching
the way that i unwind after every
session or every night is either to
watch unsolved mysteries or forensic
files
stop the ghost adventures aren't
it it soothes me it puts me back in my
zone i love it so i was watching uh
unsolved mysteries and this guy came up
to me um
in my mind i know that sounds weird and
he said excuse me um just like a normal
conversation just like you would meet
somebody in the mall right and he said
excuse me i was wondering if you could
help me
i've been missing for the last two years
in peru
and my family's been looking for me and
he told me that he was american and i
had told this is in between
waking up and you know right when you're
getting ready to wake up they catch me
around that time and i said i'm sorry
there's nothing i can do for you because
once you open that door
really can i just say wait is that how
it works once you open the door they
just stay with you
every meeting i'm reading that i do like
if i do a session like going into your
session over the phone
i'll ask somebody like you know what do
you what do you want me to stay away
from you know what do you want to bring
in you said
stay away from ghosts and things like
that horrible things so when people tell
me oh you know i was hoping that you can
get a hold of my mother or my father or
somebody that's passed on i have to
listen very specifically to who's coming
through okay
because when that opens up everybody
wants to come through so you'll hear
little conversations between you know
people saying oh he can he can hear me
or ask this or ask that or whatever so
i'm listening to all the whispers and
then i'm also listening to your loved
one coming through
and telling me to say specific things i
would be if i were you and
this is why i thank god i probably am
not a psychic i'd be cradling
in a corner crying if i had ghosts
asking me to do stuff
well all day it's just all day you're
hearing these voices the the
the ghost theft is i can i know it
sounds weird i can shut that off or kind
of ignore it
the psychic stuff never really the
psychic stuff is always on so when i
hear people tell me that they're a
psychic or they're a medium or they're
this and that i'm not they're like you
know why don't you just turn it off
you can't turn it off like you're lying
see that's that's how you know the real
ones from the fake ones if someone wants
to
have you read someone in their life that
had passed away
is that something you can just see like
right away
i gotta give it to these mediums on tv
because their abilities a lot different
than mine is
um the way that i get them i'm gonna
tell you i get them three different ways
one it will be that
they come straight through where i can
hear them i've i've had um i've said
i tell this story all the time i've had
one ghost and just because you died
doesn't mean you get your wings and
you're automatically saved and you're a
good person
i had this woman come to my house when i
was living and living in oregon she
wanted a medium reading because she
wanted to find out stuff that was
missing from her when her father died
and she was like i have a question for
you and this guy kept coming through and
he was cussing
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] this
blah blah and also and i was like who
are you and he said i'm her father
and i said i can't [ __ ] believe that
she's having me come here
and talk to a [ __ ] you're like your
dad tells you he loves you
yeah he called me he called me the f
word
yes he did yes he did and i said okay
wait a minute i had to tune him out and
the woman was sitting there and i was
like
i have to ask you this and i said
forgive me for being rude here but was
your father
racist or prejudiced before he passed
away she said oh he was a mean son of a
[ __ ]
i said well he's [ __ ] here now
head first into it i remember on the
phone call that you said that
before you started your session with
sophia that you looked at a picture of
her for a few minutes
is that how your process normally begins
before you read someone yeah
a lot of times when it's even with the
medium stuff yeah um i do a lot of phone
readings especially with kovid
so i'll do phone readings i'll do skype
readings i'll do zoom calls and the one
thing that i ask them
before i book the session is send me a
picture in a picture of you and anybody
else that you would like
insight on and then they'll send me a
picture of them their loved ones or
whoever the case may be
and then that's how i read them but i
also tell them like i told you yeah
don't tell me anything
right if you rule number one if you're
going to go see a psychic
the only thing that you need to give
them at the very most or the very least
is your name
okay but if they're psychic let them do
the work for you yeah absolutely you
tell me what you see for me
okay so let's let's start getting into
it i know sistine you want to just do
you want to talk about things you want
to stay away from and then what you were
interested in
i'll give you my spiel like i did to her
does that work for you okay so just to
let you know before you answer this
question
i do not discuss death and i do not
discuss anything that's going to scare
the [ __ ] out of you
so with that being said is there
anything that you want me to stay away
from no
perfect the second thing is for the
first couple minutes of the reading i'm
going to go in and give you what my
guides are giving me to give you
directly
and then i'll open the reading up to any
questions that you have in regards to
what i said
or if you want to know about something
that we didn't get a chance to touch on
we could do it at that time does that
work yes
okay and then the final final thing is i
would normally i would say this to a
paying client but
you're um this session's very expensive
and so is your time i want you to feel
free to jump in at any time to call
[ __ ]
do not hold back do not worry about
trying to be polite not wanting to hurt
my feelings
none of it if it doesn't resonate with
you or if it sounds off let me know
when i do hit stuff simply confirm yes
but do not give me any additional
details okay okay
got it yes all right i feel like you
know that anxiety before you take a test
i don't have i got it and i'm like i
said this to you
no don't worry about like i said you can
you can jump in and again do not be
afraid to call [ __ ] and
when i when i hit stuff just say yes but
don't add anything to it because that's
how psychics work
they drop dimes in there and they know
that clients gonna pick it up and that's
how they conduct their phony sessions
so remember rule number one don't give
them anything other than your name if
you absolutely have gotcha
so with you my love again nothing
negative let's go back to the love stuff
let's talk about what's going what holds
you back here
it's that mixture between um wanting to
be a boss wanting to be independent
wanting to wanting to prove who i am
here you got you've got to
you've got a lot of emotions behind you
a lot of thinking but again it's not in
the way that sofia thinks words
where it's over analyzing where it's too
much in her head
you you tend to get you tend to get a
little bit drained or zapped out with
your way of thinking
she takes us to bed with her and goes on
the next day here this this puts you in
a mood to where you either
i hate to use the word depressed we'll
use we'll use depressed
down or just kind of feeling ugh you
know what i'm saying and then
and then um with that being said you it
i think i think what ends up happening
to you is that you you it's not that
it's not that you're
a people person or that you you follow
what other what other people are saying
to you
but again finding that balance between
being independent and also showing that
vulnerable and that soft side of you
because i think that you fight with that
a lot
because you've probably been told you're
such a crybaby or you're so emotional
why this why that or whatever and so you
grew up she grew up hearing that and so
what she does
is she holds it she holds it all in
until she like you said she blows up
yeah you're such a rap for that growing
up
but that but that for you i mean that's
something for you to for you to
to be in touch with here because i'm
going to throw a little bit of shade to
her for a second
hell yeah it didn't know just a little
bit just a little bit just like go ahead
because she this is somebody that i
would that i'm going to need a little
bit more time to work with to develop
her way of thinking because she and for
every ant for every uh answer that i
give her
she's gonna have a question to that you
are gonna be more inclined to be like
well let's just see how this works out
for a second
you're not gonna want to mess with it
you're gonna be like well he said to do
this
remember what he said don't open the
oven until it's done baking so with you
here it's going to be a little bit more
of coming into yourself
and allowing yourself the opportunity to
let go and not hold yourself back
even when it comes to dating because
with that being said you almost got like
a virgo type energy and we went over
this too with you
during your session virgo
i i have my own podcast people give me a
lot of [ __ ] for this and it's not that i
hate virgos it's just that they drive me
crazy but i love them hey hey
i'm a virgo i drive myself crazy i don't
blame you i got a sharp ton and i be
witty but
my brain does not put me to sleep so
these are ones these are the ones that
you go to for a fast
quick answer if i look like [ __ ] you're
going to tell me straight up you look
like [ __ ]
and not hold back you and i are going to
be like well you know maybe you should
think about the blue or the black we're
going to be
we're going to feel it
no it's so true whenever she's dating a
guy i'm always the one to tell her no
it's not going to work and she goes no
wait wait but he's really sweet and like
she's like they're so sweet she's like
give it a chance give it a chance i go
no no it's not going to work
we talked about the i think we talked
about the jlo syndrome yes
i'm the jailer she's a trailer she's she
is more
um more of an emotional jlo this is
somebody that wants to be a j-lo but
ends up getting too
emotional for her own good does that
make sense
this is somebody that cannot play what
she she wants to play both roles
she wants to be that boss that boss
[ __ ] into the the independent one
i bring everything to the table here i
bring him the bacon and all that stuff
and then what she wants is also the um
the feminine side put me on a pedestal
be loved but the same thing with you
is that when it comes to when it comes
to what i said about the virgo stuff
you put on a different hat when it comes
to relationships you lose sight of who
you are
and i think that what ends up happening
with you is that you don't love it
i know she's gonna shut up
she exposed that you that you
end up that you end up picking people
that are probably a little bit
in with all due respect to the guys that
you dated people that are a little bit
beneath you
that require that require yourself
[Laughter]
virgo that's virgo for you that's
perfect she's such a j-lo
yeah oh my god but yeah like i said with
you
allow yourself the opportunity to let go
stop overthinking again i don't i kept
telling you you're so beautiful you're
so this you're so that
i don't want to capitalize on your
guys's beauty but you guys have
you guys have a lot working in your
favor you guys need to realize what you
have and own that
with with you you again you pick up i'm
going to say a little bit
more of like the more of the more
emotional men than who than you are
there there tend to be a little bit more
feminine type of energy
than you and you and what you're looking
for again don't tell me don't let me
tell you who you are so
feel free to call [ __ ] [ __ ] if you
need to but you need someone that's
going to ground you someone that's going
to be when i say it
i'm not telling you to play your
position as a woman and take a back seat
in the car let the man do all the
driving here but you need that type of
strength you need that security
you need that comfort you need somebody
that i'm not saying you're looking for a
daddy but you need that type of manly
type of person
do you have any time she says i know
sorry that's so
okay your first go-to is i want to be
optimistic i want to be i want i want to
i want to get out there and have a good
time there and i don't like to be
depressed
and i tend to sweep things under the rug
until i trip over it
huh so with you with that bingo
the the the reason why i do readings and
the reason why my guys put me in this
position here is
obviously to you know to enrich people's
lives or help them evolve their souls
how to help them move forward from any
trauma pain what's going
or anything that they're going through
here i've given you this as a you know
as a gift
what are you going to do with it now
does that make sense yes
absolutely so how so again when she goes
like that's why i told her when you go
get a reading
she's more inclined to pick up on the
reading of the read the person she'll
pick up
all their inadequacies what's what's
holding them back who they are and
she'll read them
and she she won't yeah she'll she'll
catch everything they're telling her
but she but but this is somebody that
that again her method is a lot different
than yours than yours and mine
before we move on from relationships
though do you have somewhat of a
timeline do you see me being in a
relationship
i sneaked up for sure i'm going to say
for may of next year for you
you might not understand it because
you're like how am i i'm not even there
yet so that's where people
sabotage themselves so when i go for
reading when i give people readings i
tend to i tend to stick within maybe a
year's time frame or months time frame
here
give you something easy to work with
here so we're not waiting for things to
come
and then we know i told you the past
life stuff yeah
wait so you see may maybe his face may
is
off for me may is the month for you it's
so long
no it's not long because if you stop and
think about it
who says that you can't stop you can't
start the process in january and then by
the time
you start feeling by the time you start
feeling the relationship and you want to
announce it who knows it could be in may
or you start feeling like this is where
you know we decided we're going to move
in together
you never know so don't don't hold
yourself short i feel like it's going to
be
us getting married to each other
absolutely
oh i love hearing okay that makes me
happy so when it comes to are we done
with the love stuff yes okay
but really fast here remember something
i i
when it comes to the person that you're
going to end up getting involved with
here you have to understand
again this is somebody when i say daddy
this isn't somebody that's going to
dad you or tell you what to do here the
the reason why i say
daddy or i see security is because of
the way this person makes you
feel this is somebody and i say this all
the time to people like you here not not
trying to categorize you but this is
something that's not going to allow you
to get up and walk away from the
argument
or allow you to get up and be like well
i don't want to talk about it here and
you shut down
because if you get your way if you shut
down and they let you walk away after
you shut down
you end up getting resentful later so
let this person do this to you
i want to meet daddy i want my daddy
i want daddy now i hope dad doesn't hear
this
is she i know i know traumatized
so with you just really fast with you
and your love life
hers is just really fast i'm not going
to go too far down the rabbit hole with
you with with it
but yours is going to be the dynamic
between you you and yours is going to be
different
i feel like this person's going to be
probably um
i'm not saying that yours is not going
to be an achiever but hers is going to
probably be somebody that already comes
established somebody that that's my type
she's looking
to what with her she's looking for
almost like a power couple type of
mentality
to her her i'm looking for my um
bobby axelrod and billions powers
apologies but okay no i get what you're
saying there
when it comes to your path you want to
get into the movies right you want to
get into acting and stuff
i definitely i i don't see anything
wrong with that here but in order for
you to go full force here you're gonna
have to let go of some of the
insecurities and fears that you have
and you're gonna have to start wearing
your name like like armor yeah
that's true don't sell yourself short
thank you for saying that to her and do
not let anybody
tell you what you should be going for i
know you're not stupid enough
to fall for that but when it comes to
that what the way that they're going to
try to manipulate you
is to play on your feelings because it's
harder for you to say no
than it is for her i know that sistine's
a super big person about growth and
change and she's you're i mean you are
too i think we're
at such a key point in our life where we
could really mold
who we want to be and what we want to do
so i
so appreciate all of this that you're
saying right now so with you okay i'm
not saying that you're more psychic than
she is here
but you're more you you're she's gonna
she's gonna she's gonna
take remove herself from the situation
you're gonna stay there until it
completely drains you
it's true i feel everything she does and
i take everyone's i don't want to
say too much but you've already nailed
it i i um i feel everyone's emotion and
if they're not happy it affects me 100
anybody she dates all of her friends she
takes every single emotion from them
anything that they're feeling all their
pain and it drains her
like such serious situations that she's
been in like i have to give her so much
credit that i would never do
that i'd be like i'm not taking it i
can't handle that not because i wouldn't
want to but just because
it is a lot and she just takes it as her
own pain
and you can just see it like quite
perfectly
wipe her out well your guys's generation
i'm remember i'm old
you ain't that oh you guys are a
different breed a different generation
here and what you guys do is you guys
hold on for way too long with people
instead of cutting them loose you guys
always feel like oh god i don't want to
burn my bridge with this person here or
i feel bad for letting them go
you have to pay attention who you're
around i had to let go of a lot of
people over the last couple of years
as far as like them sucking my energy or
constantly coming to me for readings
asking when this is going to happen when
this is going to happen
and me telling them it's not going to
happen until you change well this
psychic told me this
well has it worked for you no no because
you haven't changed this part about you
yeah and people always want somebody
else
to direct their lives for them or tell
them or tell them where they should be
going what they should be doing that's
not what i'm here for
no but again with you i think that you
get yourself in trouble you're going to
punch me in the mouth for saying this
i think what ends up happening with you
is that she realizes who they are up
front
and she just goes through it anyway
because in some way shape or form
maybe i could change them
[Laughter]
[Music]
sistine's motto is literally i can
change them
20 20 or forever oh it drives me
nuts i'm a fixer i'm not just i take it
off
she fixes i tell you what's right she
destroys and she fixes
i'll tape them back together no she she
comes in with the wrecking balls like
here's what we need to get rid of
and then dumps them off to you and says
here how you rebuild them for me
oh my god sofia literally puts men
through the shredder and i'm like trying
to puzzle the pieces back together
that is so just come to me when all your
shit's ready to be handled and you're
done
no i just i don't know baggage needs to
be just a carry-on
you she takes like the two suitcases
check it in
i can't do that was i a pirate in my
last life
oh actually sophie and i both she thinks
that's a joke but we're actually not
joking
um we both said that we're certain like
forms of a human in our past life is
that what you see or is it like this
person is a tree
or is this a person i think i'm either
someone else i'm a badass
pirate or i'm a golden retriever in my
last life i've i've read
it's funny that you say that i've read
people and i usually i don't like to
talk about it because i always get a lot
of [ __ ]
i give a lot of [ __ ] to myself because
it sounds hokey but i've read people
where i've even told jay
i would be very surprised if that person
was a human being in their past life
i bet you anything they they were i know
it sounds so crazy but
either they were a dog or they were just
a different type of energy i worked with
one woman
who i was like you were i i don't have
anything when i dip into your past life
all i see is is uh is like fluid i see i
see like
like waves or whatever so to me this you
must have been some sort of energy or
something
cool sophia was an energy no i was
talking about another woman
with you guys here i don't know about a
pirate or or or a dog
but um i've been watching black sails
and so i'm
going to relate to it where was i king
something's like powerful i think that
uh you again you're probably going to
punch me in the mouth she's like you're
a blatant girl
no she was i think i think you were a
male in your past life
yes i think you were male in your past
life and i think that's why you like a
male dog
no a male person like you like a human
yeah i think that she was male in her
past like there that's why she has
issues with her directness or
or again let's be honest here if you
were to look at her
very feminine right very girly very
beautiful but she doesn't come across
that way
no no yeah you i'm going to say was a
woman i have to i would have to say that
you didn't
again i don't want to scare you no
please i i love this yeah i would say
that you didn't live there i think i
would think that you that you
i i would say that you were you were a
young girl and probably didn't make it
past your teens
oh i could see that and i think there
was once
i think there was some sort of accident
with the whole family on the water yeah
but she seems a horrible
swimmer i eat swim i'm about to she
pisses me off when she gets water
because you dread it do you get afraid
of are you afraid i don't like the ocean
she can't i can tread water like for
hours that's why i was like maybe i'm a
golden retriever but
i normally have a floatation device
around me like my mom won't let me in
the ocean without like a buoy
around my waist yeah you you've just got
she's got a little girl energy to her
and it's not because she's i thought she
was gonna be like some scavenger little
girl like stealing apples from carts
like from annie or something
or a cat because you know she was
probably a little girl stealing for
other people because that's how
emotional she was at nurturing that was
the father can you uh this is weird
can you see someone as in that they
might date
like well as in okay if i was like
i might find someone like let's just say
five years two years i know whatever the
big span like could you
say accuracy of like to pick like to
pick them no
of what they look like yeah like the
scenes guy be like
like caught or is it going to be oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah but as far as like their
name and when it's actually going to
happen no
and believe it or not you guys know who
stasi is right for whatever reason her
guides were on with that
because i predicted her the initials of
her uh
now husband did you really yeah hold on
that's why her fans are out of town
yeah she she was like uh she she reached
out to me and she was like um
you know what do you see give me a
reading or whatever and i got to keep it
100.
everyone thinks that stasi and i are
friends i know her but i don't know her
that way right this is a very private
woman and so when i went to go do her
show which i think was this time was
last year in june of last year
i did her show and then we talked about
her pregnancy told her she was having a
girl
told her some issues that were going to
come into play i forgot all about that
until all the [ __ ] happened with
with her in the news that's ins do you
see any issues with her
as far as like her because you said i'm
going to be uh as far as what
just like any like changes in her life i
mean that's what i'm
like you know you've you predicted
probably that something was going to
happen in stassi's life as in like some
monument which we all knew what happened
in the news but do you see anything like
that for her
i think there's going to be a little bit
of issue with you allowing yourself the
opportunity to let go and come into
yourself
without getting irritated or resentful
towards yourself that's it that's all
stuff that you can help them work
and then as far as like people coming
into your life remember what i said her
your your person that i see coming for
you is going to be more of like again
we'll we'll just stick with the word
daddy more of like a security
i love that yeah with her with your love
life it says again this is going to be
something different this is something
that
do you want to know about it well i feel
like right it's going to be the guy
that's going to like be
pretty stable financially i don't think
i think with you that you're that this
person's going to be more of like let's
keep it moving type of vibe here
i don't because i feel like if you got
together with somebody that was too
emotional
that was more feminine than you you
would get irritated with it like i just
need you to talk to me
just tell me you love me occasionally
give me a kiss on the cheek but then
let's go to like
let's go let's go invest in some stocks
and like let's go do some skydiving
like i don't know be active and do
something remember what i said i think
during your session was it's going to be
more like a
i'm not saying it's going to be a
friends with benefit type of person but
it's uni
it's important for you to have to have
to have a banter
to have the the a good banter with
whoever you're with not that she likes
them dumb
but you like to talk you're you're
always talking about i like talking
no i'm sorry but she doesn't no i don't
if you like to talk for like until 3am
about
nothing you said that you can look at a
picture of someone and tell you the
relationship
can we bring a picture can i show you a
picture of
both of our exes that i want to the
camera but can you just tell us like
really quick what you see like whether
we're going to be friends we're going to
get in trouble no no no no hell yeah
all right i know you want me to no no no
no it could be anything in the future
yeah this one yeah it's cute oh my god
he's adorable
you're more likely just to be friends
with this person yes
because this this what's his
relationship like with his mother
very close so it's a mama's boy because
yes extremely close yeah
he's got he's got this uh or if he
doesn't get he's used to getting his own
way
and he's also used and i think they make
excuses for him they made excuses for
him as a child this is somebody where
the mother could say well you know how
he is that's just how he is
and blah blah so he got away with a lot
of stuff here so thinking so if he pouts
or he
he makes a cute little face he's gonna
always get his way oh my god okay so
just friends
just friends okay he he doesn't have
enough um for you
that's so true so this one i'm actually
very curious about you know
you make me nervous
there i feel like he wears two different
hats
so where do you see their relationship
moving forward i think you should just
be friends with this person
i'm gonna get so much [ __ ] for this okay
aquarius people
i i don't have a lot of we're gonna
virgo together well
that's a that's that's a lot of talking
that's a lot of that's the positive part
burglar is going to get upset with
aquarius because aquarius always does
what's expected of them
rather than what they truly want to be
doing and then they get irritated
because they didn't want to do that and
virgo is going to be like well why the
[ __ ] did you tell them you were going to
do that for me i was always like
do more do i do yeah yeah and with you
too just really fast
i'm going to give you just a little bit
of [ __ ] because i love my virgos here
go ahead you have to let them do that
and you have to let them
you have to allow yourself to be placed
on that pedestal i tell you that don't
come off
yeah and you too you just get out of
here yeah but she but you need to stay
up there too and not feel bad because oh
let me give you some attention now
they will tell you when they want the
attention who do you think is going to
get married first
i think she's going to get married first
i knew it
i want to i did not i coming i've been
telling my whole family i'm like i'm not
going to be the one that's going to get
married
this was so much fun oh my god i'm like
so
overwhelmed with joy go do it my love go
do it it couldn't have been
we are gonna take it and actually do it
because i know there is a difference
between hearing it and then not actually
following through and then you're
like obviously if you're not gonna like
actually grow with the information you
were received
it's not going to probably really help
exactly so
i know we will plug all of your social
media everyone can listen to your
podcast where everyone can find you
i've been taking it i've taken a hiatus
on my podcast because i've been busy but
it's still out there it's called in your
head
with chris medina it's got a big
fluorescent pink logo on it
my handles on twitter instagram facebook
are
psychic chris m my website is chris
medina.guide
you can sign up for a session there you
can go for a half an hour session or an
hour long session let me make one thing
clear i am not a clock watcher
so my sessions if you sign up for a 30
minute session it's going to technically
last you anywhere from 30 to 45 minutes
still at that flat rate
and then the hour long one hour and ten
minutes but again i can usually get it
done within a half an hour so i always
tell people to try the half an hour
first
i think we make a pact right now that we
come back here in a year's time and
we'll
see what that's doing love that idea and
we absolutely love you thank you so much
thank you thank you
for having me you guys i appreciate it
bye
from all of us here at the show thanks
for staying unwaxed
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts
at sophia stallone and at sistine
stallone and be sure to follow the show
at
unwaxed podcast your producer is will
sterling
we'll see you next week